you started then smoking marijuana
medicinally that's the official story
you know way back it was one of the old
hippies so we sort of invented pot right
would you like a Werther's there you go
oh I thought you were gonna offer him
something out yeah
believe me I'm checking the label hey
have you seen me on snoops new show I
haven't seen that no I have not I've
seen Snoopy show but haven't seen you on
it yet no well check that out all right
here promoting your next flick showing
you like hey you know I'm doing this -
we'll check it out
Kathy Bates tells you to do something
you do it
that's right what were we talking about
we got talking about your smoking of pot
you know I'm not it's never really done
anything for me and I've never really
gotten into it why do you think I should
try it because I think there's a lot of
it's much more it's much more elegant
now it's much more what's the phrase I'm
trying to look for
well it's engineer bags correct it andis
giving this a lot of power it's how I
read a lot it's it's highly engineered
you could start out with something you
know like indica like a mindo queen I
don't know what you're talking about
I really don't and I have a lot of
people who work for me
but is there one i need the kind because
I'm a little up here I mean they say you
don't want to go to the one that's
called arouse well that would actually
be helpful see that's the thing happen
from different times of the day yeah
yeah no I need some arouse yeah